and he goes and I hope you accept this
ring and I don't know no no no no Khloe
Kardashian blindsided by an unexpected
gift I think just it's just all like
weird what's happening
the reality star received a diamond
necklace from her ex Tristan Thompson
which Coco thought might be a gift for a
35th birthday and Tristan got me a
necklace when I was in Connecticut what
where he's in the tiara hotel mm-hmm
just nice and this engagement inspired
diamond drained but last night when I
get home he was like I want to give you
your birthday present go I don't want a
present from you he was a CLIA so he
gives me a card and he goes and I hope
you accept this ring and I don't no no
no no no because I just think about it
it's yours I hope not everything needs
to be by looks fully like well gauge me
right life is a challenge and if you
work at what you want you can get it but
it takes hard work simple as that
you can easily live less of a life
without working as hard and that's a few
minutes hard work for all parties I
think 400 and pour it Sophia they're all
really I'm really proud of all of them
the episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians also featured several
moments where Chloe revealed how she and
Tristan are co-parenting their daughter
true I want us to have a healthy kind
and yes a loving relationship where true
it can sleep heard mom and dad hug each
other when we see each other et sat down
with the Kardashian sisters in October
where Chloe revealed she's not putting
too much thought into dating right now
you guys have been through so much in
your life well what are you looking for
now you're not looking I'm not but I'm
not like in ten I'm just super happy and
content and I'm focused on work and like
taking care of me my body and the soul
and true and I just I'm having so much
fun with her and when I want to I will
it's not some deliberate thing they
actually have that hard about
[Music]